[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
here's the story
that was uh a few months ago
uh well actually it's a year ago and it
took place in the Akron Toledo area and
there was a fishing competition there
and you had two teammates who were
competing and they were going to win
close to thirty thousand dollars
and they found weights in the fish so
what they do is they they weigh the fish
at the end of the day and the most you
know if you add up all the uh the weight
the pounds and then that signifies who's
going to win well they put weights in
the fish and then they eventually
somebody said well there's something up
here something's not right and then all
of a sudden they opened up a fish and
they found the weights in there next
thing you know these two guys Chase uh
Kaminsky and Jacob Runyon were facing
charges and now they're going to jail
joining us now the Toledo Blade outdoor
editor Matt Markey back on the show Matt
where are you right now
uh Dan we're out in Lake Erie probably
uh
seven or eight miles out off of Port
Clinton I'm guessing
and you're just fishing or chasing down
a story
uh walleye fishing today the story was
yesterday okay
all right recap what happened yesterday
uh yesterday was the the sentencing for
uh Jake Runyon and Chase Kaminsky
so in the uh Cuyahoga County Common
Police Court downtown Cleveland judge
Stephen Galt uh listen to the defense
they got to make some statements both of
the defendants stood up and apologized
there were some statements from
the Jason Fisher who ran the tournaments
the guy that actually busted him and
then statements from the prosecution the
judge made a little bit of a speech
about how stealing is wrong and then he
uh his his sentence was uh 10 days in
jail and uh
a 2500 fine half of that fine he wants
them to donate to a local uh charity
that takes kids fishing they'll have 18
months of probation after their jail
time and they lose their fishing
privileges in Ohio for the next three
years then in a reciprocal agreement
they'll lose their fishing Privileges
and about 47 other states
are there new rules being put in place
in order to prevent something like this
happening again in the future
yes they're a lot more strict with their
inspections now in the tournaments they
are using uh you know one metal
detectors uh in some cases but yeah
they're policing it a lot better I think
they realize that uh you know the way
the thing was the judging was done and
the the check-in and all uh there were
areas where you know cheating could take
place
what was their defense
uh they they uh pled stupidity and uh
agreed greed and um you know they they
threw themselves you know to the mercy
of the court and said all the things you
should probably say when you're caught
red-handed committing a crime and uh how
much they embarrass their families and
regretted what they did and all but one
point that uh Jason Fisher the director
of the tournaments made and he's a
full-time police officer at a suburb in
Cleveland he said FBI statistics show
that when someone gets caught
feeling they've usually committed the
crime probably 40 times prior to that he
thought that was important because
there's a whole lot of uh evidence that
uh they had been doing this a number of
times before they actually got caught
how did they get caught
they got caught because in my opinion
then they got greedy and they got sloppy
they had already won you know one in
quotations a number of tournaments and
when we got to the last one at the end
of the year in uh in 22 it was for the
season Championship so probably thirty
thousand dollars on the line
and they uh they turned in fish that
based on their length
should have probably weighed four or
four and a half pounds and then the fish
weighed seven so they they used you know
if you're gonna cheat they use probably
more weight than they needed to use in
order to win the event and it was so out
of proportion to the length of the fish
I think that's what the tournament
director kind of stopped there and and
asked for a knife to cut one of them
open and they also felt somewhat
irregular because a fish the weight and
a fish is pretty much distributed
uniformly across the length of it but
with all those lead weights in the belly
these fish were going to be very uh
heavy in the center
Matt have fun uh out there fishing and
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time
all right thank you Dan Matt Markey
Toledo Blade outdoor editor